Every last part of a major motion picture
is carefully planned for years by a crew that
numbers in the hundreds. The lighting has
to be just right, the camera angles precisely
mapped out, and the lines memorized by the
actors. But sometimes magic still happens
spontaneously. A last minute or spur-of-the-moment
acting choice is so clever that it stays in
the movie. Those moments are often the most
memorable parts of a film. We've covered some
of the most amazing unplanned cinematic situations
in our video, 10 Spectacular Movie Scenes
That Were Improvised. Now, here are nine more
times the actors went off-book.
The Silence of the Lambs
It's already a terrifying moment in a terrifying
movie. Hannibal Lecter coldly admits to Clarice
Starling that he killed and ate part of a
census taker. He doesn't really need to do
anything demonstrably monstrous, and the script
didn't call for it. But actor Anthony Hopkins
reportedly wanted to genuinely spook his co-star,
Jodie Foster, not to mention the audience.
So he came up with his little snake-like hiss:
"I ate his liver with some fava beans and
a nice chianti."
(Hisses)
Raiders of the Lost Ark
All of the fight scenes in the first Indiana
Jones movie took weeks to choreograph—including
a lengthy sword vs. whip battle. But when
the time came to film it, Harrison Ford backed
out. He’d come down with food poisoning
the night before shooting. He simply couldn’t
go through with the elaborate physicality
of the scene. So, he ran an idea past director
Steven Spielberg that became one of the Indiana
Jones series' most famous moments. Instead
of fighting off a swordsman with his whip
in a few minutes, Indy just shoots him.
End of fight. End of scene. And Ford was free
to go.
Good Will Hunting
As Robin Williams' character tells a story
about his deceased wife waking herself up
with her own sleep farts, Matt Damon can't
stop laughing.
"She used to fart in her sleep."
"Sorry I shared that with you. One night it
was so loud it woke the dog up."
The laughs are genuine, because Williams,
a gifted improviser, made up the whole story.
Both the hilarious bit about the farting—and
then the really sad part about how intimate
moments like these are what defined a happy
marriage.
"How do you like dem apples?"
Dumb and Dumber
The script for this Farrelly brothers comedy
called for Harry and Lloyd to get on a hitman's
nerves by arguing about jelly beans. The comedically
agile Jim Carrey and theatrically trained
Jeff Daniels thought the dialogue was weak.
So they tried out several ideas, eventually
deciding on...
"Want to hear the most annoying sound in the
world?"
(Yells)
"Guys! Guys! Guys!"
The Godfather
The scene was supposed to be brutal, but simple.
High-ranking mobster Peter Clemenza, played
by Richard Castellano, is on his way to a
hit with an underling when his wife asks him
to pick up some cannoli. As scripted, Clemenza
and his stooge kill the guy, and Clemenza
utters "leave the gun." But when Castellano
filmed the scene, he remembered the other
thing his character was supposed to do. After
the hit, he quipped:
"Take the cannoli."
...instructing the underling to grab the box
of cannoli on the murdered man's dashboard.
Delicious.
Zoolander
Truly great moments of improv work when they
fit in perfectly within the movie's themes.
Case in point: Derek Zoolander asks an important
question to David Duchovny’s hand model
character:
"So why male models?"
Duchovny delivers a long monologue about how
male models are involved in an assassination
plot. But afterward, Ben Stiller had reportedly
forgotten his next line...so he asks the same
question he'd asked moments before, leading
to one of the greatest improvised responses
in comedy history:
"But why male models?"
"You serious? I just told you that a moment
ago."
"Right."
Pretty Woman
Richard Gere’s character Edward, was supposed
to present Vivian, played by Julia Roberts
with a fancy necklace. While filming, Gere
decided to prank his co-star, and quickly
shut the box.
(Laughs)
Roberts was taken aback, and her laughter
and surprise were so genuine (and charming)
that the take stayed in the movie.
The Warriors
As the Warriors nemesis Luther, actor David
Patrick Kelly was only supposed to ominously
bang a bunch of bottles together. Instead,
he added a little something extra:
"Warriors...come out to play!"
A schoolyard taunt wasn't in the script, but
it so perfectly built up the drama for the
final confrontation that director Walter Hill
let it stand. It's now far and away the most
famous line from the 1979 cult film.
Aliens
After a massive attack from the aliens kills
a whole bunch of humans, things look pretty
bleak. The line was written as, "That's it.
What are we going to do now?" But actor Bill
Paxton was just feeling the vibe of Private
Hudson, his mouthy and eccentric character.
As a result, he ad-libbed the lines he'll
probably be best remembered for until the
end of time:
"That's it man. Game over, man. Game over!"
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know which improvised scene was your favorite...